la gauche qui s'incline donc à nouveau
ps europe écologie et les filles n'ont
pas réussi pendant l'entre-deux-tours à
séduire de nouveaux électeurs
aucune progression du score bonsoir
eléonore elle nous allons revenir avec
vous sur ce scrutin régional en ile de
france pour justement cette liste de
gauche et les quelques sièges finalement
obtenu fiom en effet même 53e moules
frites pour l'union de la gauche voilà
la récompense pour cette deuxième place
obtenue lors du second tour des
élections régionales en ile-de-france la
liste le rassemblement pour l'écologie
et la solidarité
mené par julien bayou secrétaire
nationale d'europe écologie les verts
n'a pas réussi à détrôner la présidente
sortante de la région valérie pécresse
le score est néanmoins honorable 33 68%
contre 45,92 % pour la liste ile de
france rassemblée pour rappel à l'issue
du premier tour la liste indépendante de
julien bayou s'était classé 3e sur six
listes pour se maintenir au second tour
devant celle d'audrey pulvar parti
socialiste 5e et celle de clémentine
autant la france
insoumise 6e il avait alors décidé de se
rassembler pour le second tour créant
une liste unique notamment pour contrer
le rassemblement national arrivé
deuxième au premier tour et pour tenter
de battre valérie pécresse objectif à
demi rempli donc le rassemblement
national étant arrivé en troisième
position lors de ce second tour au soir
des résultats julien bayou était tout de
même satisfait de ce score se soit
vraiment je crois qu'on a on a réussi
quelque chose d'assez inédit et qui
insuffle un bel espoir avec clémentine
autain et audrey pulvar on a on a mis le
projet au coeur l'écologie des
solidarités c'est ça qui nous rassemble
le cap on l'a
ce soir ça n'a pas suffi bien sûr
valérie pécresse l'emportent avec des
salles méthode un des anathèmes des
insultes les injures défectueuse des
montages mais l'espoir est là et ce que
nous avons construit en ile de france
nous allons poursuivre et avec la
déclaration de julien bayou longtemps le
climat sera électrique l'ambiance sera
électrique au sein du conseil régional
on imagine bien pour qui mens notant
toutefois élus dans le département de
seine-saint-denis cette union était une
aubaine pour ces élections
objectif faire front commun aux
prochaines président
ça y est je trouve que nous avons réussi
à agglomérer nos forces et au fond à
créer une dynamique et un espoir
donc c'est pour ça qu'il ya cette
ambiance ici c'est du crois que chacun
chacune mesures que nous avons réussi
quelque chose qui sans doute est un
point d'appui pour l'avenir alors si on
regarde un peu plus en détails pour le
département des yvelines ce sont six
colistiers de la gauche qui vont siéger
à la région
exactement 6 sièges et deux d'entre eux
seront occupés par ghislaine ce n'est
d'europe écologie les verts
elle était déçue mais optimiste hier
soir au soir des résultats et un autre
par benoît hamon de génération qui lui
était plutôt incisif et revanchard c'est
un rendez vous malheureusement manqué
mais d'un autre côté il faut quand même
se se dire que la question écologique la
question de l'urgence écologique
manifestement confirme le fait que de
plus en plus de personnes se rendent
compte que c'est un vrai sujet et on a
malgré consolidé en tout cas une base
très très fort de personnes qui
aujourd'hui met l'écologie au coeur de
leurs préoccupations comme madame
pécresse sera pas candidate aux
présidentielles parce qu'elle a fait un
beau coup plus mauvais score que
monsieur wauquiez et et monsieur
bertrand d'ailleurs je ne souhaite pas
la droite ni à la république donc mais
pendant six ans va lui je pense que le
conseil régional d'ile-de-france va
regardez à la virgule près e
sa fidélité aux principes républicains
je peux vous dire qu'on va pas la lâcher
qu'on va lui montrer ce que c'est
l'intensité démocratique
quoi qu'il en soit la majorité de
valérie pécresse devra compter sur la
gauche et les écologistes dans
l'opposition du conseil régional on l'a
bien entendu rien n'est moins sûr qu'ils
seront se faire un temps miss ried
au lendemain de ces élections régionales
l'union fait la force mais jusqu'à tout
au moins jusqu'aux présidentielles ou en
tout cas après les présidentielles merci
au nord